let's say that we had a function defined
by the infinite series so we're going to
go from N equals one to infinity and
each term is going to be X to the n plus
1 over 4 to the N times n to the fourth
and we could even expand this out when n
is equal to 1 this is going to be x
squared over 4 times 1 to the fourth so
it's just going to be 4 when X is equal
to 2 this is going to be X to the 3rd
power over 4 squared 4 squared times 2
to the 4th power and we know this of
course is 16 times 16 which would be 256
but I'll just leave it like that for now
plus when X is 3 this is going to be X
to the fourth over 4 to the fourth power
times 4 to the fourth times 4 to the
fourth so it's really going to be 4 to
the 8th power and we'll just keep going
on and on and on just to get a sense of
what this function would look like this
function that's defined by an infinite
series now what I'm curious about is for
what X values will this function
converge to finite values or another way
of thinking about it let's come up with
the radius of convergence or the
interval of convergence for this
function now since we've just been
talking about the ratio test you might
say well maybe the ratio test is useful
for what X values is this thing going to
converge so let's apply the ratio test
so let's take the limit the limit as n
approaches infinity of the absolute
value the absolute value of the n plus 1
term over the nth term and so for this
particular case this is going to be the
limit as n approaches infinity so the n
plus 1 term I'll do this in orange so it
will be X to the n plus 1 plus 1 so it's
going to be X to the N for
- so it's going to be X to the N + 2
over 4 to the n plus 1 4 to the n plus 1
times n plus 1 to the 4th power and
we're going to divide that by the nth
term which is just going to be X to the
n plus 1 over 4 to the n times n to the
4th which of course is going to be the
same thing as the limit as n approaches
infinity oh I can just copy and paste
this of this so copy and paste that
times the reciprocal of this we're
dividing by a rational expression that's
the same thing as multiplying by the
reciprocal so times 4 to the N n to the
4th over X to the n plus 1 power
actually let me just clean this up a
little bit now can we simplify this well
X to the let me get another color here
so X to the N plus 2 divided by X to the
n plus 1 well n plus 2 minus n plus 1 is
just going to be 1 so this is just going
to simplify to an X in the numerator and
then let's see 4 to the N divided by 4
to the n plus 1 so this is the same
thing as this is the same if we divide
the numerator and denominator by 4 to
the N this is going to be 1 and this is
just going to be a 4 so this is going to
simplify 2 and I forgot my absolute
value signs don't want to do that so
let's keep my absolute value signs here
the whole time this is going to be equal
to the limit as n approaches infinity of
the absolute value of we're going to
have X and to the fourth in the
numerator so let me write that down
we're going to have x times n to the
fourth in the numerator and in the
denominator I'm going to have 4 times n
plus 1 to the fourth well what's that
going to be well if you expand out n
plus 1 to the fourth if you expand out n
plus 1 to the fourth it's going to be
to the fourth plus a bunch of bunch of
terms and a bunch of lower degree terms
this is going to be the highest degree
term so if you distribute the four it's
going to be four n to the fourth plus a
bunch of lower degree term so let me
write it that way so it's over four I'll
use the same colors for N to the fourth
and to the fourth plus a bunch of lower
degree terms now what's the limit as n
approaches infinity here well we have
the same that we want to look at the
highest degree terms we want to look at
the N to the fourth the fourth degree
terms and so it's really going to be the
coefficient on this and one way to think
about if you divide the numerator and
the denominator both by n to the fourth
these are the only terms you're going to
have an X in the numerator and the
denominator going to have a four and all
these other terms are going to be
divided by some power of n so as your
limit approaches as n approaches
infinity all the other terms are going
to go to zero and all you're going to
have left in the denominators of 4 and X
in the numerator so this right over here
the limit as n approaches infinity is
going to be x over 4 I should say the
absolute value of x over 4 so it's going
to be equal to the absolute value of x
over the absolute value of x over 4 and
now we can apply the ratio test or I
guess we were always applying it but now
we can really test do the test part of
it and the ratio test tells us that if
this limit right over here as long as
it's as long as it evaluates to
something that is less than 1 then our
series will converge and so we just have
to say that this expression right over
here has to be less than 1 so our
function is going to converge to finite
values as long as the absolute value of
x over 4 is less than 1 and this is
dividing the absolute value of or the
absolute value of x over 4 is going to
be the same thing as the absolute value
of x divided by 4 since 4 is positive so
that just has to be less than 1 multiply
both sides by 4 won't change the
inequality since 4 is positive so you're
gonna have the absolute value of x has
to be less than 4 and so just like that
we have defined the radius of
convergence this right over here is the
radius of convergence for
our our function of our infinite series
radius of convergence or if we wanted to
write that same information as an
interval of conversions we would say
that X X has to be less than 4 or
greater than negative 4 this is the same
information right over here express this
way this is the interval interval of
convergence interval of convergence so
these are the X values for which this
original function here is going to
converge to finite values